con un puente aéreo y la apertura de
fronteras arabia saudita puso fin a un
bloqueo de casi tres años a qatar el
príncipe heredero saudita y el emir
catarí cerraron su enfrentamiento con un
abrazo en el aeropuerto de la ciudad de
a lula este acercamiento se produjo en
el marco de la cumbre del consejo de
cooperación del golfo en la que se firmó
la declaración de la ula un pacto de
solidaridad y estabilidad para
fortalecer los lazos entre las naciones
aunque no está claro el contenido del
acuerdo ni las posibles concesiones de
qatar además se hizo un llamado a la
unidad frente al desafío nuclear de irán
hoy necesitamos desesperadamente unir
nuestros esfuerzos para promover nuestra
región y enfrentar los desafíos que nos
rodean especialmente con las amenazas
planteadas por el programa nuclear y los
misiles balísticos del régimen iraní y
sus planes de sabotaje y destrucción
adaptados por sus representantes el
boicot se inició a mediados de 2017
cuando arabia saudita a los eméritos
árabes unidos bahrein y egipto acusaron
a qatar de acercarse a irán un rival
regional en varias guerras como la de
jane wint y qatar también fue acusado de
patrocinar a grupos terroristas algo que
doha negó
los boicots incluso exigieron que qatar
cerrará su canal de televisión
internacional al yazira el avance se
produce cuando joe biden está próxima a
llegar a la casa blanca y es probable
que se acerca irán en un intento por
darle vida a un deteriorado acuerdo
nuclear la medida de arabia saudita
podría ser un gesto de buena voluntad
para permanecer cerca de la casa blanca
después de que donald trump abandone su
cargo